Austin Matthews actually kills penalties this
year so it's a loss to have him in the Box a
much better power play that the Le face to your
point doson got it on there Paul Mary scores
and 40 seconds in the Islanders grab the lead
at [Music] [Applause] home it's pretty simple
when you break it down it's harder to do easier to
say and harder to do but good face off win there
good work by the wings to jump in and get that
loose Puck and then you know what sometimes when
you don't have anything you put the puck on net
great job by Paul Mary to gobble up that rebound
off a Dobson shot we talked earlier about Dobson
I talked on the point about dobs and how he's been
so offensive now Anders Lee snaps one to Oliver
walstrom who draws back in sent one bouncing and
rebound given up by Martin Jones spins back out to
Adam pelic and glove save PA Mary tried to spin it
deep and Bobby McMahon the undrafted rookie got it
along to the Speedy Noah Gregor sent it on at ilas
soken John T Scoops it up and the first little
caval of booze as tarz races in backend and bought
off by sokin back he seems fine but big hit there
by Mayfield and then talked about here is NY said
it was to his left knee yesterday in practice
got a stick caught in the skate felt awkward
he worked it on net sookin had a rebound pop in
front of him and the ultra talented Speedster up
bikes had it broken up by Brody at the line well
done he lost it Holstrom out in front barel hold
shoot save rebound out in front and clear wide of
Jones picked up at the line by Sebastian AO lays
it back down for forbat centering for walstrom
and a save Jones picked up by berzi numbers for
the leaves lillig with neander he feeds berzi
and a shot gets locked loose for berzi and
behind the net Riley from Brody Riley hangs on
to it off the leg of walstrom back to the line
Brody held it in moved it Riley into space they
score it's McMahon from Greer and the Leafs tie
it they've tied it in the first they have the
Islanders had their chances and then you know
overall I thought the Islanders dzone has been
okay A couple miscues here but you can see they
get their layers back that shot gets up and
deflected but then they lose it right there
there's a missed que by the Islanders defense
that's how Bobby McMahon is able to skate right
through the high high slot area right there
there's a a transfer and then he's able to
get open and Sebastian AO can't quite no timeline
yet for his return we talked about pel Mayfield
Miss time AO for for twoos out right now came
over from St Louis so they they've had their
struggles in the back endend neander turns right
back in with speed jordano for nander trying to
time it up and S scrolled [Applause] out Colgate
in the building as BCI told you watching this one
before they play a game here as well the Raiders
in the house he tied it up start of the second
loose in front Matthew scores on a backand that
squirted to him he shovels it past soken and 26
ticks into the second the Leafs lead and it's
number 32 for am34 we talked about the quick
start for the island ERS in this game but now it's
Toronto Maple Lees and we just talked about how do
you defend him how do you defend the best goal
scorer right now and you stay close to him right
now they lose track of him and right in that
situation it's JG Pou number 44 in blue has
him he's close to him and then he leaves him and
and watch you can see JG padro right there 44 he
turns around turns his head and then he lets
Matthews in alone now he's it's not just Paso
there's a lot of blue jerseys Ang ball wheeling
up from the corner couldn't get it back to the
line for doson picked up by call yarro and he jams
It Forward another great B check by Pierre angal
there showing his speed through the mutal Zone
coming back doson turned it over Matthews scores
again off a giveaway he's got two
in the first three minutes of the
second that's something they've been trying to
clean up we talked to uh Lane Lambert about it
Noah Dobson is trying to make a pass he's
got somebody right on him he fans on it
he's not hard enough on the puck we heard
L lamber tell Emily Klan in his interview
that they've got to manage pucks that's
a perfect example you're in the dzone
they have some fresh legs coming on drop
for Thompson skating out High one timer
got blocked on the way in off the Stick of
Alex Romano Romano break wide for barzel he
surveys drops for Romano speeding in he
scores oh what a snipe from Alex [Music]
ranov that's one way to get the crowd back up
and out you see great Puck workor here by the
Islanders good creativity keeping it outside
but then for ranov what a snipe who knew he had
that in that is a great shot Far Side tucks it
right inside the post and you know but you can
look the reason he has all the space to take
that shot is the movement he he mentioned it
briefly not just offensively not so much on the
power play but allowing players to play hockey
allowing them to use their Corvette off the
end boards nearly timed it up perfectly tried
to connect back in the direction of Brock Nelson
and then a failed clearance from jordano whipped
across here's barzel at the half wall he stands
barzel back for doson flading it up [Music] SC to
[Music]
the Islanders and what they did well is they
kept they retrieved the puck how about that
play right there by Kyle palmary jordano could
have iced the puck should have iced the puck
paary prevents it and then they go to work here
and it's good Matt barzel work along the wall he
draws two Defenders all the attention and a
little Nifty backhand pass creates a better
angle watch barzel pull it to his backand
and he gets a better passing angle back to
Noah Dobson who has all the Time in the World
to rip Gates it up ice met by n swatted along
at Center turned over Matthews for Marner and
Over The Line Marner PS it top of the circle
with a shot block It Away by soken an Islanders
team that is allowing the second most shots per
game in the NHL only better than the Sharks
touch down by Lee Corvette is in Corvette
Deni how about this transition through
the neutral zone by the Islanders this
this is where they struggled on Tuesday against
Vancouver they got dmed up in the neutral zone
quick one-touch pass in a triangle formation
Anders Le beautiful job to Spring Bo Horvat
for this opportunity and what a great pickup too
by Horvat with he's got defenseman on both sides
and then he tries to go well down at the wall by
Nelson here is doson for Romanov a shot short side
and a save by Jones by Martin Jones to keep the
score tied at three 33 our score this has been
40 we talk about the calmness on the some of
the lead players how about for meing they just
so much Poise Nelson fashing oh and a stop
as fashing had a chance to Fire and give the
Islanders the lead John sis on the ice with
berzi and nander as Riley got dropped at the
redline turnover knee Lander toward the net
still loose for taras and soken fight fits him
off Corbat out there for the faceof one back
to doson doson for Bale sces it's [Applause]
over set up by the way on an icing call they
get the offensive zone face off it's a faceof
win Noah doson recognizes he gets that pu
back he takes a lot of shots from the point
and it's a good awareness from Noah Dobson
to look and see that Matt barzel has eluded
his coverage gets in the back door there it's
his backand a beautiful feed by number eight
to 13 four points for both those guys and a
huge win here at home at UBS the crowd went
nuts barzel ducked in behind mccab who had
the icing trying to connect with Matthews
it sets up this yeah you know when you look at
that icing call too they were trying to set no